[Music]
today is primary election day in new
york city
and voters are making history when they
fill out their ballots the top contest
on
is the democratic party's race for mayor
the winner will become the overwhelming
favorite to be elected in november
this primary will also be a big test for
a system called
ranked choice voting voters are asked to
pick their top
five choices instead of choosing just
one candidate
ed o'keefe is covering the primary for
us ed good morning good to see you in
person mr good morning everyone ranked
choice has been used in other cities
but if all goes well here in this
primary race in new york today it could
lead other cities and states to adopt
the method
rank choice kicks in if one candidate
doesn't get at least 50 percent of the
vote
and with 13 democratic candidates on the
primary ballot today
that's likely to happen stay focused
don't get distracted grind and vote this
year in new york
big apple voters are making big choices
in the race to succeed mayor bill de
blasio
are you guys ready to get out the vote
i am all about getting people out to
vote
top issues of concern include rebuilding
from the pandemic and affordable housing
but especially crime and policing where
people don't feel safe on our streets
and on our subways
murders in new york are up nearly 14
percent year over year
shootings up 64 percent yes i do it's
caused a rift between candidates like
brooklyn borough president and former
police captain eric adams
who supports more traditional policing
tactics this is more than just
an increased number in police officers
but really
how are we deploying them whole city
and civil rights attorney maya wiley
who's a leading liberal in the race and
wants to redistribute a billion dollars
out of the nypd's budget i call it being
smart and growing public safety and
right size in the police department
this year for the first time new yorkers
are ranking their choices for mayor
ranked choice voting has been used for
years in san francisco and minneapolis
and across the state of maine
but let's face it new york is new york
and with apologies to frank sinatra if
it can make it there
the hope is it would make it anywhere if
rachel's voting can make it in new york
city
i think it will make it anywhere rob
richie is ceo of fair vote a
non-partisan group that pushes for
election reforms
like ranked choice voting right now the
current system really isn't a level
playing field so
conventional wisdom kind of runs the day
right um
and so rancher's voting allows voters to
sort out the candidates
and give them a fair shot and you can
vote for your favorite without
worrying whether that candidate has you
know passes the viability test
here's how it works voters can rank up
to five candidates
if one receives more than 50 percent of
first-choice votes
they're the winner if not the candidate
with the fewest votes is eliminated
and those votes go to the politician
people rank next on the ballot
a process that repeats until it's down
to two candidates
and one has the most votes the change in
voting has led to a change in strategy
two top contenders former presidential
candidate andrew yang and former
sanitation commissioner catherine garcia
have teamed up on the trail if you do
support me please also support catherine
garcia on your ballot
garcia doesn't explicitly endorse yang
but says it's about promoting the new
voting method
clear i'm not co-endorsing we are
campaigning together we are promoting
rank choice voting
some voters say the new system compelled
them to pay closer attention
i didn't want to just choose anyone to
fill those spaces but i really did the
research and wanted to make sure i was
making an educated decision
and while many like it for me it was a
piece of cake man
others say forget about it i don't know
i think it's confusing
all right new yorkers pack your patience
because it could be weeks
until we know a winner due to the
state's absentee ballot rules the
campaigns we spoke to say
there's so much uncertainty about who
might win because of the crowded field
and this new way of voting this is going
to be a really good question it's not
just who you put on your ballot but who
you leave off
that's part of the campaign too and
those and there are those charges that
you know
people argue it might disenfranchise
certain that's because
hot button debate just in the last few
days of you know is this potentially
causing
especially candidates of color
potentially to suffer
the others turn around and say no
because now everyone
in essence if you put your top five down
it's very likely that one of your five
potentially is the winner but everybody
has to vote for everybody
right well yeah that's one thing you got
to fill out all five slots
because otherwise remember that uh
runoff election we were waiting for in
georgia it took several weeks the
proponents of this system say this is
your runoff yeah and so we can get this
done in several days or weeks instead of
months that's the idea
all right ed thanks so much